let's get into audience questions for
the week first one from Sergio Sergio
says hey David can you give us an update
as to how many people you have banned
blocked or muted on different social
platforms for the David Pakman show some
time ago you gave the numbers and my
guess is that in the era of alt-right
trolls you've had to block way more
people yeah this is pretty funny I don't
remember what the numbers actually were
when we did this question a few years
ago my sense is the numbers have
definitely gone up in the era of Trump
but not that drastically and I a listen
I don't know if these numbers are high
or not but I'll tell you what they are
on YouTube we've got about 550 people
blocked okay about 550 people currently
are blocked from commenting on our
YouTube channel because we really have a
very high threshold for banning people
can go in there and call me a Jew cuck
they can say the show is terrible they
can really do almost whatever they want
but when they go in and spam the exact
same comment across so many videos that
we notice that's gonna get you blocked
if you go in and you're just attacking
people in a very particular way that is
completely destructive to the
conversation on the channel we're gonna
block you if we notice it and again we
get 50,000 comments a month on YouTube
it's very difficult to do that with
everybody but they're about 550 people
blocked that seems like a very small
number to be given that we have almost
four hundred and fifty thousand
subscribers like it seems tiny compared
rise of the channel so we'll allow
trolling certainly not any direct
threats of violence the other thing is
impersonations oh yeah people make an
account that's david pakman show but the
I will be like an L sure so people think
that it's us and they'll say horrible
things we can't have that we block those
and I know a lot of people will hear us
say this and they'll say but David
here's one person who's doing exactly
what you said and here's another one
who's impersonating we just don't see
everything we just don't because there's
so many comments we can't that would be
a full-time position it almost would be
yes one we currently don't have a budget
for on Twitter I've got a few hundred
people blocked but I have a lot of
people muted that's a thing I admit that
I do that on Twitter I will only block
people if they are participating again
indirect threats hate
attacks of a particular nature if
there's people who are just spamming my
feet all day with political
disagreements over and over and over and
over again
I won't block them but I need to be able
to respond to people that are being more
productive and not have my feet flooded
so I'll use a feature called muting
where they don't know that they're
blocked I mean I'm sorry they don't know
that they're muted they're not blocked
so they can still read all of my tweets
I just never see any of their app
messages to me it is a fantastic feature
the ability to mute is excellent I love
that because then they feel wasting
their time and they don't know that
you're not seeing anything it's
beautiful it's absolutely beautiful so a
few hundred people blocked on Twitter
but several many many hundreds who have
been muted and they don't know who they
are but listen if you've been tweeting
at me for two years asking me the exact
same question and I never respond it's
probably because you've been muted so I
will I will admit to that Facebook we
don't have that much of a problem on the
Facebook page so we've only got I think
about seventy-five people blocked on the
Facebook page what will get you blocked
there is directly attacking other people
and also spamming the post feed with
links to random pages of your own and
stuff like that but we've only got about
75 people blocked on what about your
Flickr your MySpace yeah plus I'm not on
any of those but the one were I who so
the lowest block threshold is on
Instagram okay on Instagram I am on
there I post some little clips from the
show but mostly I'm on Instagram it's
more like my personal page I'm actually
sharing pictures from if I go to a
concert or a trip or whatever and when
people show up there and start insulting
me or just making irrational political
comments I have a very low threshold I
will block them because that's just not
the platform for that yeah so I've
probably got you know my Instagram
following is much smaller than lots of
our other ones but I've probably got a
hundred or 150 people blocked on
Instagram which percentage-wise I think
is probably higher than others so that's
where we are I mean there's there's been
definitely an increase in the world of
the red pill online all right but not
exponential not exponential
think many of you will be very happy
about that